make it fast I'm gonna God make it fast
I'm in a goddamn hurry we've been
laughing about it all break yeah that
made me really super happy she's getting
to the bottom of everybody yes and I
call the party that they all played
Craig Gass what's going on man
nothing I'm excited to hang out I've
been doing a lot of phoners there's like
certain people that will pop up in in
the news that I know my phone will start
ringing and and gene Simmons is doing a
ton of press oh yeah yeah so I had them
in twice I got I got buddies who will
call me up and go hey we got gene
Simmons on it's 7:00 do you mind calling
it as gene and just kind of backtracking
everything at 7:30 and kind of doing a
goofy thing that so do they know that
you're kidding the fans are know yeah
because I'll make it really obvious and
I'll just say you know the the DVD that
huge station in Pittsburgh I was on this
morning and Randy and I gave ya Randy
bound right and I did some silly thing
about well you know let's get serious
for one second right now there's 28 days
until Christmas okay
and they say that prostitution they
refer to it as the oldest profession in
the world so right now I'd kiss online
calm let's say you have a sister you
have a mother are they a kiss fan how'd
you like to watch them get pounded by
kiss go to kiss online.com and have a
real boyfriend experience it's so
over-the-top it's so stupid it's
believable how would you do that yeah
what buy my girlfriend a [ __ ] kiss yeah
yeah but not not not Eric not not Eric
in Tommy yeah no but hey hey can you
jerk them off oh they're in the makeup
you're not giving up your [ __ ] to
[ __ ] to to to uh to Eric and it's got
to be through ass I should say that is a
weird thing that happens at shows is
that there are guys who want their
girlfriends to go [ __ ] one one of the
guys in their favorite band yeah it is
kind of crazy like I've had a couple of
threesomes in my life I don't think I
inspired that level of sexual energy
from audiences real I know I know you'd
look at me and you'd think it was ah
beeping oh I think your wall here
all right you used to describe that
threesome that you were in or you were
in some kind of situation with Ronnie oh
yeah it's true story was that a
threesome 100% she sucked my dick
she's a bunny ranch girl and Ron was
[ __ ] her after the buff to the AVN's
in 2004 January before you hosted I did
mean Jameson and and and Dennis HOF is a
buddy Marv I still never been in the
bunny ranch and he knows and he's
invited me out to dinner garden so he
might be up to his room he goes hey man
come on up or hanging out so I went up
to his room and I walk in and Dennis is
eatin girl's [ __ ] on a table on a
[ __ ] table at the Venetian Hotel and
Ron and the girl just sitting there
another bunny ranch girl and Ron is
[ __ ] another girl kids casually
talking he'll he's not even that dirty
when he fought she was literally just
[ __ ] you're chatting with her I didn't
believe that ron jeremy [ __ ]
recreationally I mean it just does so
much of it that you would think that it
wouldn't even you know be a thing so
there's a girl Ron's banging her and
he's really [ __ ] her and Ron goes I
told the story nice people you know hey
man looks like she needs a dick in her
mouth so I stuck my dick in her mouth
and then she blew me for five minutes I
didn't do it for long stage fright um
nah my dick looked pretty good it was
because again it was just for the story
the fact that I'm kneeling on the bed my
hands on my hips is pretty enraging but
Ron looks like he really dressed for the
occasion
but instinct is really inside of her he
looks like he's just pretending to [ __ ]
but he's actually [ __ ] he just pulls
his dick out of the top of his he
doesn't care yeah he's athletic - he
doesn't care and same outfit yeah comfy
sweats a big gut and yeah it was uh it
was fun it was it was a fun moment just
to do it you know had you heard any of
these stories that are coming out now
about Ron yeah I've heard that ron was a
guy who likes to get his dick wet and
it's porn conventions he would try to
[ __ ] I never heard that he was quote
unquote forceful I've never heard that
but again maybe they wouldn't just tell
me that I never heard that at all you
would just see what I'm here saying that
she used to grope a lot yeah I mean but
that was when you would see that at porn
Kevin
whenever I saw him it was always in a
silly moment I never saw him being dirty
that's the only time I've ever seen him
be sexual but again he was [ __ ] her
when I walked in the room do you feel
like you're in a tough spot because
you're friends with him does that put
you in any no I mean I but I just didn't
know I don't hang out with him I've seen
him in Dennis at other events but it's
always been in a public setting
yeah I don't so I don't necessarily see
him in [ __ ] mode a couple of women have
accused him of outright rape right yeah
one or at least one girl did but he's
defending himself pretty adamantly yeah
he didn't do it I there was a girl I met
years ago who told me a story and I
thought well it's ron jeremy and the
circumstances they were gonna do a photo
shoot together and he said listen I'm
gonna let me just why don't we go in the
bathroom and let me just get some shots
of my dick in your mouth and I'll send
it to an agent which in itself is great
you know it seems like you know I wasn't
there to do that and that's what
happened and I was like huh well why'd
you do it but it is ron jeremy
you know i mean it's you know so yeah it
was kind of a weird story but but yeah I
guess he's getting be in from a lot of
events now yeah I mean he's being way
over the top like the way he's just
grabbing you know it's like you can't
just grab his I guess maybe he was just
looking at like hey it's 1985 it's like
it's not anymore
it's a different generation of girls
yeah which is what you're waiting for
like the rock music world to just get
blown apart because that's where all the
craziest there is yeah but a lot of
those it's kind of maybe I'm sure this
stuff has happened but it's probably
very hard to argue that point when it
said well you want backstage as a
groupie you know it did and they did all
the guys gotta go well she came back
here to [ __ ] and they the road he tells
you you're gonna go [ __ ] they [ __ ]
like it might be hard to prove that and
there's part of it is the news cycle
right like they're gonna latch on to
like the big powerful Hollywood people
the actors of the day the louis ck's of
the world who have all this fame like
the the rock guys who are unless it's a
big rock unless it's a be like yeah
looks just like Jon Bon Jovi or oh yeah
no yeah now you know enormous yeah and
if you did something that was out of the
norm but if you [ __ ] a girl backstage
it's it's you know yeah it's kind of
hard to complain about that we were both
drinking him and he had sex with me yeah
yeah I mean that that yeah that could
happen I know that Jimmy and I and
Florentine we all have stories about
trying to get backstage to meet our
heroes and getting stopped I know who
says the girl can come but not you
that's like in in rock star when when
Mark Wahlberg before he joined Steel
Panther or steel dragon steel is like
watching the the band manager give out
passes to all the girls and just girls
and he goes hey man you think I could
get one of those like they would like
nice still to this day can walk through
a crowd and go here here's a pass for
you but you can't bring your boyfriend
and women will come at right well yet to
find people I'm doubt if my if my wife
that's we were talking earlier she at
the jay-z show cuz you know you got to
do to get to jay-z's you gotta suck a
roadies dick I know you're not getting
near jay-z without sucking the roadies
day no of course not
and what would you do if she came back
with a really a bunch of laughing photos
with jay-z two hours later two hours
yeah I'd be bombing here in the parking
lot
yeah you were texting her and you were
seeing that it was delivered but not
read right Jess have to work tomorrow
where are you delivered not read where
are you you I know you're really calling
right to voicemail like oh she's sending
me a voicemail yeah oh yeah cuz it rang
twice it's not that it's not it rang
twice and then I just went right to work
yeah bye ring ring goodbye Oh oh no I
don't think I'm going back for the
second night yeah I don't actually I
wouldn't I wouldn't lose anything ever
happened to I feel too guilty like give
God for a [ __ ] you got [ __ ] attacked
and right oh drop her home and then
scream left me there yeah wouldn't you
can't but it would be very upsetting
I don't know how guys allow that [ __ ]
it's I'm a cuckold I don't get it it's
gotta be dirty to me and they're all
sucking genes dick no no what do you
mean if I was with a girl and she went
to set this point my life no you
wouldn't let her section Simmons now
well you wiped that not dirt if I really
loved her because it wouldn't turn me on
oh like cuz I love gene or I love Ozzy
Osbourne's you want to suck genes take
no I wouldn't touch jeans pants you
wouldn't know what if he was like Jim
you offered to share my banana I say
yeah I did
- mr. Medina was a real banana he'll
give you a discount and you can touch it
for 2995 yeah yeah no I wouldn't touch
his penis or Ozzy's penis no no I would
not allow a girl I'm with to suck their
penis all right maybe are there guys you
would let your woman that you'd want
your woman to [ __ ] yeah but I wouldn't
want to know them Oh personal
relationship I couldn't have nothing
pornographic it couldn't be a guy
idolized something to watch just to
watch ya like dirty but I couldn't know
the guy won't come there couldn't be a
hero or a friend you're right I've had
trains with friends it's fun but it's
not too sexy right and it's not like
that's a the girl in the train is like
girlfriend no not at all I've watched
you know eivol you many times I've
watched boss gets dumped dick sucked
boss has actually gotten uh many times a
bunch yeah you know just watch but
there's a couple of girls who like their
David they went down and they were fine
with it maybe the way we did after
comedy shows well they liked rich but
the way we did it I was I was never too
imposing so it was always like yeah I
was almost like a creepy boo radley
they're like all right get back there
right was this when rich had his long
curly hair yeah when I ate that girl's
ass in Central Park yeah she loved it
what was the squatting was the scenario
there she's black girl she's really
pretty
uh-huh walking by a club in the village
yeah and she goes oh my god her and rich
start talking and bah-bah-bah and he has
a great chemistry with her so I think we
went to a dirty porno booth Wow and I
guess her and rich were in a porno booth
like watching movies or something and
then we're all on we're all on [ __ ]
Broadway and 54th or whatever it was and
Boston her kissing and you know I'm
standing behind her and she's pushing
her ass back she had a beautiful little
rump and she was like you know she was
dirty
I guess the poor get all [ __ ] hyped up
uh-huh and uh III started kind of like
licking her ass cheeks on Broadway I was
wrong British car start it's a really
true I guess you know [ __ ] you know 93
years no I would love to do that now
that place is long gone Giuliani ruined
everything this is what was in before so
I'm [ __ ] kind of like kissing her ass
on Broadway then went to Central Park
and she stuck rich his dick and she
stood up and she pushed her ass back so
I squatted behind her and was eating her
ass you had a don't just stare so high
as he's remembering it was I didn't [ __ ]
her anything but it was fun just to eat
her ass
and then engine not only out and then
this invoice is like how come I'm like
my legs are sore and bosses like why
didn't you I was ago squatting is why
didn't you kneel I don't like I don't
get grass in my pants that's what he
pointed I didn't realize that he didn't
want to get grass in my pants yeah so it
was pretty uh it was pretty hilarious
you know speaking of all this ass eating
and [ __ ] ya know if there's an etiquette
in a train like is anybody ever crossed
and etiquette where you go the [ __ ] you
doing yeah you got a the ones I've been
on have been you know again tepid but
you have to know what you're doing like
if to know what your role is like a lot
of times I was invited in late so I knew
I care I'm gonna sit here to get my dick
shot you're going to you know plus my
dick has problems in front of people is
that right yeah I can't function with a
friend in the room I can't get a hard-on
with a buddy in the room it just too
weird so ron jeremy it was okay but not
in front of like like yeah that just I
don't know thank God my dick perform
then it wasn't even full for law you
know it's just for long enough yeah long
enough yeah get the credit for it yeah I
just kind of sat there and watched still
counts
yes does anyone ever accidentally come
on another guy I mean I've got to my
life but ya know you never know Mike no
okay never you've been in some trains no
we were talking I'm glad I'm glad you're
here Craig
yeah we were talking to Nico on
Wednesday so something happened to him
well we're trying to get some back story
cuz Nico he's kind of shrouded by
mystery yeah I know much about this kid
and he used to work at Pathmark and
while he was working at Pathmark he's at
sex he's 20 he's had sex with one time
with one girl
good for you yeah pretty good though no
no girlfriend he's not had a girlfriend
yet here's a want one why would you want
to be weighed down no that's exactly
right I support it but he told us he he
had sex
here's the story as I remember it Nico
you can correct me if I'm wrong we can
older man get a sec of the man right no
what
that's incorrect yeah okay so he had sex
with a girl right girl his age more or
less yeah well how old do you 20 choose
13
is that correct my faction officer good
good good but this happened earlier this
year he had sex with this girl who he
found out recently had a kid however we
did some backtracking and Niko doesn't
have anything to worry about because if
his numbers match up she would have had
to have been at least four months
pregnant when he met her when the other
okay
however Niko said that he did not know
she was pregnant which four months is
pretty far along that is pretty far not
know yeah and keep in mind it's also his
first time having sex right it is so he
doesn't know much about I mean he'd seen
women before yeah but at four months I
think it's it's possible then he said
that then he showed us her Instagram so
we can see this is the girl and she was
a good looking girl she not terribly
overweight which means that she would
have shown while pregnant and also on
her Instagram there were no shots of her
pregnant or with child so so a lot of a
lot of questions arose then he told us
she looked good she did look tight yeah
then he told us that he had to dodge
bullets at Pathmark and we said we mean
dodge bullets and he said he used to do
it with what kind of talk was it made me
figure out what you say like talk there
was a lot of slick talking and we said
like what and he said he would he would
do a good job but other people would not
do good jobs and we said those two
things don't correlate like that that
over here is one thing in slick talk is
another thing yeah and then he just kind
of mumbled until the end of the show so
we never really is that is that am i
incorrect is there are 100 percent
correct okay and he was implying that
his slick talk but he couldn't provide
any examples of slick talk with what
were the bullets that you were dodging
it's like talking yeah just slick
talking I'll give an example to Craig of
all of a slick talk bullet that you
dodge
I don't have an example you must have
not one however you had all weekend to
think about it I didn't so a long
weekend too and then also Monday so it
was actually six days almost a full week
yeah I say you're dodging bullets at
work you're dodging what kind of bullets
like but you almost got fired like
harassment okay I guess you can see our
harassment Oh harassment from work like
you were harassing the girls cuz I guess
yeah like flirting but just didn't
realize what I was saying flirt like are
Kelly he's just like cuz I'm a flirt and
you were aware that trouble was coming
in da Jose but I didn't realize so which
what he was mentally dodged the bullet
yeah they just went over his head like
he walks like he's in the matrix on a
regular basis alright so like the
bullets will fly over and whether he
knows they're coming or not yeah have
you got a pretty good game on talking to
women
no no well but you got the one was she
drunk when it happened no I would hope
she was so was it just luck that got her
going she's like a lot of flirtation a
lot of slick talk and then it happens
how'd you get her to our house how'd you
get to our house that's not true that is
yeah that look on your face how'd you
get her to our house where'd you guys go
first
I didn't get it there else where's your
Jeff sex ler it didn't happen
[Applause]
for you know Nikko is the man for they
go wait a minute Nikko spits it out and
now let Niko how many girls have you sex
with suspected yeah I'm not only do we
know everybody Meryl just pull the mic
down a little bit different homeland did
you know after Wednesday that if this
comes up again on the air you just kind
of got to come what's coming and you're
like I just gotta tell him to try just
didn't think what I was saying before I
said it
yeah when you gave us the black girls
Instagram I figured you would have liked
that yeah you were right if I didn't
give you something you would have just
wouldn't been happy right at least you
got some photos we know that girl
right and you like you know that you're
telling people you had sex no I just
made someone someone up and actually
they blocked me she did she blocked you
why I really don't know did you want to
have sex with her at one point you
blocking me so you would reach out to
her mmm-hmm I'm not I didn't really
imply that nobody would reach out and
talk to her in general yeah what did you
say to her wait like recently you know
when she for she bought you I haven't
even reached out to her yeah she just
blocked even to me you must have reached
out to her there must have been some
kind of slick talk how long ago did she
block you a year ago Oh what did you say
to her before that that caused her to
block you
I think I'd sent a I tagged during
something that wasn't a racist joke was
it no it was a dick pic no no it was
like one of those life quotes and I
tagged her and I was like this is you
cuz she always would like put that stuff
on her facebook or whatever and it was
just funny to everyone like reacted to
it in a funny way
oh yeah she didn't like she got annoyed
she did you write her back and go hey I
was like I saw her work and I was like
she just didn't talk to me and I was
like yeah it kind of
Sansa to get sensitive because she puts
up those motivational quote from a fun
of her and maybe maybe she thought you
were making fun of her I didn't realize
it the joke was at her expense yeah yeah
so why not just tell her when you [ __ ]
her
I guess she's mad but it's no big deal
goes do you think when you do have sex
you're gonna be good at it probably you
know yeah that's good because that's
what the you know what gave it away from
me was even before that conversation
when you said that you lasted like 10 or
12 minutes
does it get that [ __ ] out I don't know
it's 10 or 12 no no but you never came
back up but I knew that was not good for
you for admitting to it because other
people don't I just want to see how long
I can go without were you opening with
crack now or were you guys hoping that
he would hold on to it I didn't nobody
really perfer for his sake I contemplate
I was like can I hold on I don't I'd
have to do a lot of research to bag all
that's like I couldn't do it because you
a lot of research on what sex is like no
I just back up the story the horik wires
to back up the students to tell the
truth to be humiliated that actually put
in some work we respect you for T we
respect you for telling the truth
finally sure you we knew you were lying
we know so it would it just kept you
long we said to each other we were gonna
talk about it we came back yeah Jim and
Sam have you guys ever lied about being
with a girl you know in a roundabout way
but I was never one to go I [ __ ] that
girl and I didn't yeah me I know I've
never said that I
I used to inflate numbers when I was
younger like yeah yeah like that's
pretty in court yeah but I never
specifically said that's the one which I
think Nico would not have said yeah I
[ __ ] her unless we had been like okay
well who was it that okay well what okay
well then when and and how and poor Nico
apparently the Travis dog has a clip of
yeah from the after show from the after
show podcast Nico telling Anthony and
Rob where he adds does it air here or
just a podcast
it's just a pike okay yeah just it's
like a 15 minute podcast that Robin and
Anthony put up on their Twitter and
stuff you have the clip listen for
anything
yeah other ones yeah but this is uh this
is I guess this is where here he has sex
Sam's got some really organized notes on
me oh yeah I got it there's my Mike
Craig gas plug sheet which by the way
his album and DVD the worst comedy show
ever is available at Craig at get gas
comm for $5.00 and here's my clips all
right Sammy Vegas yeah hopefully
complete douche that's overly was good I
know all this back couldn't think of it
oh oh really complete is I know I know
just a talking ran through it for 10
seconds and nothing came out well I'm
like Bethan losers good they made in
Everett see an ego that would be it's an
effort that would be Jim having a little
slick talk I tried and I failed and
apologized one happy where did you learn
your trade just stupid [ __ ] you idiot
um okay yeah this is Nico telling us
telling the boys where the sex took
place which we all know now you know
continue to lie on the podcast that's
good I would have been I'll tell you
here if you had lied still today it
would have been sad like we would have
been like oh no back liars
if you had told them that if but if you
hadn't lied if you had wanted another
podcast I would have been furious yeah
you beautiful no I wouldn't have done it
for them thinking about that girl how'd
you ever jerk off thinking about that
girl no what no I jerked off thinking
about it over through absolutely I jerk
don't think about the two you together
have you ever jerk off thinking about
any girl that works here it's serious no
come on how about choice you answer too
quickly I don't know that many people
here I'm not yeah there's no attractive
women here I
ever have you ever jerk off thing about
anybody who worked with you at Pathmark
I don't never worked at Pathmark
shop right don't we vent do you have a
favorite who's your go-to favorite girl
to jerk that's a great yeah but I'd say
our whole name I don't know wait oh yeah
girl you ever jerk off to any of the WWE
women but know someone in your personal
life sure I've never done that I'm just
just born just born yeah imaginations
never a girl that was really nice to you
that was really wait
last I heard you jerk off in the shower
like a mother to your mom male 35 so how
do you explain to your mom why she's not
helping
why you keep getting why your all your
phones have water damage I don't okay so
where do you jerk off like I watch it on
my iPod no toilet yeah wait how why not
you're [ __ ] my bedroom I mean I
sometimes but I just he said he told us
that he can't shut his door don't shut
that I can't answer the door if you have
to show your bedroom door you can't shut
your bedroom door why he's a
masturbation fiend
is that what that is they don't what you
jerk you want because when Nico's
allowed to shut his door he get scabs on
his penis from his femur semester did
you ever say to them I'm a grown man why
can't I shut my door yeah they said you
can get out of my house what you're like
look at my [ __ ] business you think a
child can grow this hold you 20/20 and
your [ __ ] door has to stay
open it what are you doing when you
sleep yeah well I'm gonna share my room
or no privacy in your house you don't
smoke weed in the bathroom do you smoke
you don't really smoke weed you don't
give me that impression yeah like what
could you be doing with the door shut I
hate that jerk-off you know the dump
your loads you say this to them mom you
we do is like next time just pull your
pants down to like your thighs and lift
up your shaft and say these things are
full and just pointing your balls where
am I supposed to end you know it's empty
these puppy comp uh pees keeps it in the
slit these puppies ma that's how you
talk to mom when you're a teen I did
absolutely that's how I created a
healthy separation I won't even ask that
she would say where am I supposed to
answer this you don't so wait you know a
lot when I was a teenager and I got
punished right I forget what idea but
they took my doorknob off yeah I did I
[ __ ] up they took my doorknob off
except the block module now to jerk off
I take my secret I would put a sock in
where my door handle was and I would
take a sneaker and jam it under the
actual door uh-huh but I was on Punnett
like I knew I [ __ ] up right they
didn't just do it so I couldn't have
privacy
do you ever stay up like late past when
your because what time your parents go
to bed my mom doesn't sleep your mom
doesn't sleep she hardly sleep does she
just want to make sure you're not
jerking off she does like your parents
are obsessed with you now man huh she's
like kind of sick but she doesn't really
sleep well she's older a couple years
ago she had a double seizure oh she's
got a medical he's not staying awake at
night like she was like what would she
know if your door was shut at night
she'd probably open it and fight and
then over the night yeah what do you
what'd she do if you was locked
she kept ask what would she say she
buddy why snore like you'd be like you
want to watch me jerk off every exam
want my privacy would I sleep what would
she say just I probably just smack in
the mouth you would I was so that bad
that furry mouth of yours that bathroom
is your sanctuary when you get to lock
that do you tug your dick in the
bathroom sometimes yeah where do you
come in a towel so that's the evidence
see it's a towel why in the towel flush
it down the toilet oh wow flush I like
it out like a paper towel I'll say a
paper towel not a toilet paper
why not toilet paper or paper towel
paper towel you probably have so many
toilet jams in your house no because
they don't buy your mom no every time
you walk in with papers just easier
coffin that's really apparent [ __ ] got
it so sorry disgusting embarrassed take
dumps in there mom had a big lunch I'll
be in here for a while where's the
lotion he's gonna have some kind of [ __ ]
fetish when he gets older he's gonna do
something about people [ __ ] just
turns me on
it's a crazy thing to do use lotion I
have before I don't I've jerked off in
the bathroom many times don't I can't do
it I hate that make you feel bad it's
disgusting
but if you drag off while you're on the
toilet you could just come in the toilet
yeah do that
no yeah you can't and you get down you
don't like you let it fall in the toilet
you know what I mean it lands were and
then it just kind of dribbles down into
the toilet no you can't he looks
different that way not the same or you
could stand up and point it down that's
the most effective thing no it's
horrible
you think so no I lied jerk off
sometimes I'm talking on skype and
because I want to show my gut I have a
paper towel that I'll put on my chest
it's the worst thing ever
I'll be like I'm gonna come and I put
the paper towel exactly it's the worst
it's totally unsexy yeah I understand I
understand the gross thing I have no
defense and how often do you how often
do you please yourself more or less
three four days a week that often
sometimes like if I if you walk in there
if you walk in there have to [ __ ] and
you realize one of your parishes were
there and dropped a deuce and you gotta
get over that's get over it get a spray
first you got to get the demons out it's
standard but only if you have a place to
do it
like it's not standard if you have to
sneak into the bathroom and I don't see
I just like I'm going to bathroom do you
tell them first you announce no do you
ever say hey it's Nikko Shady's time
no I can't believe you can't close your
door at 20 that's crazy to me what do
you think Troy yeah it's weird it's
weird right yeah they obviously don't
trust them for something what this just
all it's all me my brother it's not just
me it's just yeah I know it's your
brother
mmm I have two brothers how old are they
my older brother's 22 my younger brother
is 12 22 year old they can't close his
bedroom door he has Asperger's okay so
are they doing that okay are they doing
that so because they don't know what
he's gonna do and they want him to feel
normal like hey no one can close their
door it was a my brother's fought one
time in another room my guy so pissed he
took the door knob off the door cuz they
would always shut in the door it's like
I got no door now now this has to stay
open so there's a hole through the door
you think when you get babied a little
bit because obviously your brother needs
somebody to take care of him you feel
like they're like you haven't been able
to age and do a proper 20 year old
because they're taking care because he's
your older brothers and it'll give more
leeway to my younger brother she's like
well he wants to shut his dorm a little
bit all the time I'll go in his room
he's 12 he's just like it's not the
[ __ ] anyway he'll lock the door my
dad gets really mad cuz he keeps the
door you think your brother's jerking
off I hope nobody is he's 12
so wait okay she holds all these
Asperger's he functional yeah but he
needs assistance he needs a little bit
more attention but he understands
doesn't understand if they don't they
also probably want to make sure that
that brother's not in the thing IB
that's all sort of normalized yeah that
makes a little more sense
okay look his door stays open so does
yours and so do you because if you do
can close your door he can he's gonna
feel like an outcast and then we share
the room oh you old about we share the
room I've never had me the one that has
an esper yeah wait Oh younger brother
has his all his own room yeah the 12
year old is driving crazy how does that
work that you don't have I don't
understand that why does that what
you're trying to get a job so much
because you want to move out you really
want to move out yeah they know I have
no place they go how come your older
brother doesn't have his own room well
he won't it was just me and him we just
shared the room because we had an extra
room that's like a spare room in case
people came over you share a room even
though you had an extra room like we had
that room at the time when we were
younger just a spare I guess
it was a guest room but then it just
turned into where we put everything so
we're just really know where they go and
then when I my little brother came along
they moved they just changed that room
into his room and then we have we have
another part of the house but at that
point my uncle was living there and then
he moved out so they started we started
fixing it up so like there we made the
living room on that side or you can just
go and play like Xbox or whatever with
you of it there's no there's another
there's another bedroom like we just
literally the other day like cleaned it
all so you moving there no I'm just
gonna try and convince my parents well
you live in that why don't you two share
a room I own a year old my cousin's
coming from Italy for the first time on
Friday so they had to make that into a
room so she had me staying for a month
so I was thinking like hopefully when
she leaves I'm just let me have him what
you these why wouldn't they I don't know
I'd have to commit would you bring your
cousin I've never met her no but the
thing is when that'd be great if she
she's the greatest cousin if she
wouldn't you be creative his cousin was
in the country for a month and she I
think my I can't I hope great that is I
can't say I mean it's a level of great
that I've never
it's literally if I woke up and Ozzie
said Jim I moved in with you that's the
level of greatness right knocked her up
did she speak English not that well as
far as I know it's your picture yeah
yeah yeah um but the thing is after why
can't after she leaves why why would you
want your own you wouldn't want it who
the [ __ ] wants to stay with her brother
I want my house it's you're sharing the
space you ever try to sleep in the
living room just like [ __ ] it I just
sleep in the living room with you yeah
any communication cousin at all online
or I've never really talked to her to
talk to her you work Travis says you
should bring the cousin and see the big
American radio show it sounds fair yeah
there you go first cousin yeah perfect
she gets into town on Friday there's a
genetic problem too she's in town Friday
right cousin and we like really play up
me go to try to hook up the real
going his first cousin Niko knows
everybody knows all the famous people in
America oh my god dude Niko you got a
Dilla tude like that photo
he is downplaying how attractive yeah
wow she's she's really attractive really
cute Wow
Kelli get pictures of her thanks man Wow
wait oh my god she's really cute you
have to bring her in the shot I'll be in
Florida and I'll be listening every day
for the cousin to come in the gram you
know she said she wanted to see New York
oh yeah you bring them in and tell her
that Wow look at that picture
Nikko runs New York any comments no look
at this wow she's cute dude but you
needed that picture show Sam that
picture all right bring in the cousin
get a translator speaking really as
alike as well yeah what's the comment oh
wow it says holy [ __ ] exclamation point
it's just a wonderful button
yeah just really she's a good-looking
girl she's got a lot of habitat there's
a bunch of pictures of her in pajamas at
the end of the next month so that's why
she found oh wow maybe after she leaves
you can see attractive girl yeah I do
that all right there you go yeah yeah
that's great
oh my god yeah I don't know what's her
English grasp I don't know
okay boyfriend it's 24 she's hot you
might possibly like you know like in a
different country though yeah yeah
zombie 2 is defined you should probably
you should probably just ask Troy if you
can have your phone back let's just look
at the pictures just look at him dump
them killed
looking at all the pictures don't lose
your mind just to eat here and there
just going through every picture little
dusting yeah nothing you know you don't
a Slean on barns scorched earth yeah he
should I get your phone back and she's
gonna be sleeping in the next room what
happened but why would try an eggplant
emoji nice guy how'd you end up working
here
we got lucky
we're happy to have you do you guys
interview him I know it Travis did
doctor who's - Travis who did the
interview with Nico Anthony oh Anthony
and Rob good job
how'd the have the traffic court go
yesterday it went okay yeah do you get
out of the ticket I only had to pay $89
how much we supposed to have to pay
probably like 500 what was the thinking
for slick don't someone is doing
something the school zone zipper open
made a turn on private property but
there was a sign like a three-foot sign
that said no through traffic and another
car in front of me literally that's what
the sign said no through traffic right
and there's a car in front of me that
did it and what the signs say no through
traffic okay no through traffic right
you're saying no through traffic yeah
yeah you understand where to put
emphasis and what words but it's like
you understand what you're gonna say no
just say no you don't have to do it
through traffic
yeah no traffic right yeah absolutely
tell the judge but no sign said no
through traffic what does that even no
turn on red right no turn on red right
yeah yeah I guess they looked at this I
avoided a light but I would still have
another light right yeah sure but
another car did it so they pulled us
both over and neighbors bought tickets
okay so the take was five seven what was
your exclusive he did it my lawyer
that was a relative so I didn't have to
pay but my dad's like I got to send or
something oh you're sure your dad's
gonna pay no he wants me to pay for
something and send them something
because I don't like a gift yeah but you
wouldn't take money from us the lawyers
what was the lawyers how'd they get you
out of it like she talked about the
prosecutor they just a lot of times just
about you like hey look I'm poor I don't
have money you have no criminal record
though right now so what he should have
been I don't know is my first ticket
what are you gonna buy her my dad to the
condoms cupcakes and just a few and send
her a link to your favorite point say
something this is what I come to and I'm
[ __ ]
just started anywhere every female that
he comes in contact all family what was
the worst case the worst case scenario
for the what were you potentially
looking at five hundred and reduced to
eighty nine bucks and urinations yeah
good for you I think with a clean record
you would have been okay yeah and then
it would have boosted my dad's insurance
and he wouldn't have of course I've
already I already yeah you don't wanna
catch so uh okay so what I want to hear
a little bit on this side i we've not
heard the clip on oh yes okay where does
sex take place who talks like that take
a special broadcaster no no let me hear
that again you wanna hear it again I do
we're just sex take place yeah Shane do
you think it was cool when he said it
like that no no right
where'd you pop a boner Shane where he
sounded professional I don't think he
ever sounds professional we're in a
building her building yeah in a building
why wouldn't you say her apartment you
see a building in East our stories so
crazy place just sound that sounds a lot
better than like a building in East
Orange you know it's like we're getting
somewhere but we're getting somewhere
well it might take a while it might take
till after the break to get a little
slow I'm sorry what break it's a [ __ ]
podcast no I think he meant the vacation
oh sorry okay I love that in a building
what a great answer
amigo it like gives like the the small
amount you tail possible yes and just
let you finish his sentence for him it's
a good trick like in a building in her
building yeah was she living in a
building yep whatever whatever they said
well which building was it there was a
building well was it where you work yeah
State Building 85 yeah it's like the
dumb kid in making a murderer that dead
nephew and a see yeah Brittany you stab
them with a knife right sure yeah and
then you what did you do next head sex
no you chopped her up yeah yeah chapter
after chapter up yeah I'm gonna get
outta here in time for school right yeah
yeah you leave the door open
no you gotta do it with the door open
quietly yeah you do yeah yeah wow that's
awesome
did you ever do it while your brother's
asleep no I think that's why by the way
no I think he does it when I'm asleep do
you are you really asleep or you autumn
no I felt the bed shake what we have
bunk beds why are you the top or the
bottom top that's I'm talking but you
have that's why they can't lock the door
but of course did the brothers in the
room and their bunk beds yeah yeah
anyway you said your brothers were
fighting one time they were fighting in
another room how old is your older
brother 22 how old you younger brother
12 what the [ __ ] kind of fight were they
having video games like a fistfight
argument
oh boy I mean it could've led to that
but it was just a big argument and my
dad just got sick and tired of it he's
like you know what
cuz they both kept shutting the door and
locking it but no one else can go in
there and just sit down so it was like a
family room like a living room right so
he just took the door knob off for like
a good mom so why are you being punished
for that like you have to share a room
you've bunk beds it's a meet why I lived
at home till I was 30 so I'm not
criticize you living at home do your
bunk beds that's just a little weird no
doorknob got a man for anyone yeah we
just in have a separately had like at
one point
side by side but we just didn't have
enough room to refix the room did you
think yourself like maybe if you get
bunk beds you'll have more room for
activities yeah yeah he's beaten karate
yeah your brother with Asperger's he is
he the bed above you or below below
balloon and you can feel the bed shaking
sometimes I felt that a couple times and
we just become best friends probably
yeah
oh you're in the top bunk that sucks do
you like it sometimes I mean sometimes
it'll get too hot or too cold so I'll
sleep on the floor
what cuz I just I can't get comfortable
like at the Heat's on real high it'll
get too hot can you turn it down or you
don't control the temperature just
thought it comes up whenever is it an
apartment or a house house that sucks
you can't control the heat in your house
now you can flip it up or like you can
bring the thermostat up or down but it's
it's out of set temperature so once you
go recently I guess if the call if the
room gets cold it'll come on so we send
out a couple degrees you know but like
at night it just gets really cold
yeah the Nortons were not in the
air-conditioning at night people and my
mother was [ __ ] bat ears if I went up
there it was like 6:00 in the morning
and she would hear me flip it on to you
it's like the air starting to come out
and turn it off did not have our
conditioning overnight now try to fall
asleep before the air conditioning went
off it sucked we didn't do that either
my dad would be like oh no it's totally
comfortable and he's just in his
underwear sleeping on top of the covers
and uncomfortable like no this is great
Nico do you have a bumper on your bed so
you don't fall off yeah I've never
fallen out of my bed no 39 years yeah
but you also pissed your bed as recently
as six months ago so I'm not saying I'm
a perfect example I've never done borrow
your brother I'd be worried about that I
said [ __ ] will dribble down on him right
yeah good just wrong piss I've never
pissed them good kid so you have a
little bumper like that so you don't
tumble out yeah it's not like that kind
of like it has stairs like the the
stairs are like a drawers so it's not
like that
well you have stairs instead of a ladder
or yeah like stairs but the stairs are
Joris will they pull
and you can put like closing it it's an
adult bunk bed Jim yeah oh don't you
bang your little head on the ceiling
sometimes oh I see where's the actual
stairs wait instead of there being a
ladder yeah there'll be stairs I like
going up and then you just oh it's on
the outside areas are pullout drawers
nice and then there's a drawer on the
bottom of the bed to the big drawers do
you guys share them in the maze we have
certain drawers yeah but I haven't seen
like that is kind of like that yes you
really want some privacy don't you yeah
maybe better right sometimes yeah where
do you want to move in into why don't
you a hot-dog get a place he's not
making any money right now but yeah
well hot dogs living large I mean hot
dog is basically his mom's the the
relationship has changed he's basically
his mom's landlord like he lets his mom
it's his apartment now why he pays the
rent he pays everything what what's the
number one reason that you need privacy
is a jerk off no I just forgot I didn't
really do it your brother first that
makes sense oh and you can't bring a
girl home like that's got to be like so
like part of you is like why am I even
gonna bother trying that will not happen
no key are you allowed to have a
girlfriend yeah they want they like they
want oh you don't want women have wanted
to come over you had a bring home one
who block you see what your dad thinks
about that old-world Italian yeah no
they wouldn't go over go with you know
what happened people are on the guy my
dad wouldn't let me stay home is that
right he's like don't bring home any
guys he said that he told me don't bring
home any guys you think they're worried
that you might be gay I think my mom
thinks she's asked me why did she what
did she say to you I was just eating one
time it's just like do you like it I
don't know dog and you weren't biting it
your mom said do you like men yeah and
what did you say how much no boys I hate
them when they're not small anymore mom
right right you were you insulted by the
question right because you're not gay
right wait outta left field unlike men
why don't you think you should have a
girlfriend this way no she just I guess
she saw something not lying that she
doesn't like what did you say porn no I
guess she's posted no I just like women
together or whatever I guess she's not
that my parents grew up where you in
their household there wasn't you
couldn't they couldn't have that there
wasn't gay so she was in a really yeah
can't i gay
kind of mood that night when she I was
just like that's what their parents
raised them to be like you couldn't like
shame on the Catholic school right
couldn't have it so wait so the lesbian
porn she didn't go for I guess just like
a lesbian why was she why did she belong
to that site yeah should just worked up
about gay people she asked if you were
in the guy I'm going cuke and the
cucumbers so your um your mom does not
want any point in the house she just she
yeah my boy what do they do do you make
enough money to move out or no no I'm
making those interim bucks right now
you know alright do you work as well as
this yes okay we'll help me do you make
good money there are no I make decent
money
the interns get paid now I mean there is
all right forgot making money here so
I'm here as an intern everyday and I'll
work the weekends do all interns are
video for the most part yeah not
everywhere Nico's everywhere I applied
to was just not paid that's why you're
like you were like let me come too
serious let me get some of those bucks
there's a good money or no here yeah
it's it's better than what it could be
okay trying to get paid right so when
you do that egg how much would you need
a month to move out like what's an
average rent we're in Jersey right yeah
I mean I need a lot well how much is
rent there for two-bedroom apartment you
and a buddy thousand a month he's got a
mommy so you need five hundred a month
plus utilities and then I get paid every
two weeks I don't a thousand a month for
a two-bedroom apartment I don't know I'm
asking how much is it I don't know
Jersey Jersey yeah it's high I mean I'm
not I don't know a lot about it but it
that's it's where you because will you
live by the city yep I'm Emma cuz you're
not buying Hoboken no right your your
and what forty minutes in the city you
should get you 12 your old brother to
get a job and move in with you yeah
yeah yeah but you don't have anybody
that you would want to move in with
right now you don't have any good
buddies no yeah what about Anthony would
you want to move in with Aunt why don't
Anthony and Nico move in together that
will be awesome that would be awesome
yeah you're a baker all the time yeah
it'll be great for the show and you both
you both live in Jersey I'd have to do a
lot of problem solving for him you think
so yeah I love that
I'd have to solve his problems too oh
yeah probably yeah
we hear Nico's slick talk tactics yeah
we just heard it
no when the way he just there's a clip
of it reiterate oh we got so okay when I
leave this store you know they'd ask
like can you give me a ride home you
know just give you our home so I don't
I'd be I'd be married so she asked for a
ride home and you [ __ ] her no what's
in it for me you know I just start
bringing that up she prostituted herself
for a ride home dawn eventually is just
like you know fine whatever
Nico said what's in it for me would you
really say that forgot you for a ride
what's in it for me probably that's like
loan-sharking dockworker talk yeah
what's in it for me
Nico's parents talk to him about sex God
you know that sounds like it sounds like
the pickup lines of Mike was the guy who
had a heart problem last year the
heavyset machete machete it sounds like
you guys be good roommates you a Mike
for sharing well why don't you would you
move in with would you move in with Nico
you need a place to go you know
roommates make it a lot easier you get a
you get a two-bedroom so it's not like
you have to share a bedroom but you know
you can oh you can afford half a 2-bit
yeah that's not gonna happen why you
like living with your parents really or
my right yeah yes your mom asks you to
move out on a regular basis on a regular
basis but I would live by myself then
I'll just live by myself why do you want
to live with Nico it'd be too jealous
Rula would be too jealous of you you be
in the man yeah why don't you want to
live with Nico because he's a creep and
he's a creep says the guy who says I
just want to [ __ ] messages yeah but I
want Nico and I jerk whoa
[Laughter]
[ __ ] jerk-off you [ __ ] weirdo yeah
great
so why do you think he's a creep Anthony
I mean he's making up stories about
having sex like that's creepy just say
you're a virgin it's fine you made up
you made up the fact that you were cold
when you were obviously I was actually
cold no no you weren't too afraid to say
the Troy was mad at you he wanted
another guy to like him you're
criticizing Nico for lying about being a
virgin but you were lying about a
co-worker being mad at you I feel like
that's you know Nico's lie is a little
more understandable no no no oh really
no do you think your life would make
more sense yeah and I was kid wasn't
alive I was cold damn it Jordan I got
mad he's getting oh I'm not kidding I'm
just cold
I'm a cold person are you are sorry you
mad where's he keep walking away from
money yeah why would I be mad well I
don't know why you won't move in with
Nico I just don't want to move in with
Nico you were actually involved do you
think it makes sense his theory of which
lie do you think makes more sense I mean
they're they're both straight lies right
wait which lie is more justifiable like
which lie to you go like yeah I could
see where somebody would lie about that
I can see why Nico would lie about a
virgin yeah it's like embarrassing is a
guy at age day who's not gonna lie about
right roomful of guys yeah you want to
be one of the fellas yeah you don't want
to say I'm a virgin because the guys
making you give you a good ribbing yeah
we took beds we talk about that stuff a
lot on the show we talk about [ __ ]
socks yeah yeah yeah everyone seems to
be the door the guys think I'm a creep
because I don't [ __ ] jerk-off so
Anthony Anthony do you think that's a
stupid lie he told I mean it's not a
stupid lie but I mean I'm
she's call him a creep for not [ __ ]
and then also said he's a creep for
lying about being a virgin if you if he
knew that the vibe was I'm a creep if I
don't [ __ ] wouldn't it make sense then
that he would lie about that so that
people wouldn't think he was a creep
right Yeah right
I just don't think that my life was
worse than his it was at all so I'm
gonna end up with that I'm gonna end it
with that drop the mic
but he's admitting that he lied of
course he did he knows he liked but why
what is the real reason that you won't
move in with Nico because it Bruno it
makes I swear to God financial and
logical sense he doesn't make any sense
like at home I can [ __ ] it I closed the
door she doesn't she's asleep why would
you want why did you want to [ __ ] in
your mom's house instead of your
apartment you know I would want to [ __ ]
in my apartment I will [ __ ] in my own
apartment I don't want to live with Nico
make a [ __ ] creep you would live with
Anthony right so you got you've got a
guy right here who's like makes money
he's making money he will cover half the
rent and going yeah I'll be your
roommate can you cover half my front
right now yeah with your nabisco job and
your interning money yeah
Anthony what are you telling girls when
you bring them they are you telling them
hey my mom's nice you know they gotta be
quiet yeah don't let the stairs creak so
my mom only hears one set of footprints
in bed you're so happy for him you think
that Anthony's mom maybe thought that he
was a little squishy too yeah both make
the same amount of money just work on
the same show yeah you both need privacy
yeah and you got you can get away from
your parents and have your own place
anything he doesn't want anything he
wants to stay with mom oh Anthony put
this call through Jeff and Maryland is
not happy
oh no Jeff comment yeah I'm just
wondering if you guys are doing some
Andy Kaufman thing where you're
intentionally trying to irritate your
listeners by spending 45 minutes on your
he's not a loser
we're just kind of interested in his
life and the fact that he lied about
getting laid we had to follow that up I
love when one guy named Jeff is like I'm
gonna speak for the listeners here I'm
the union rep and the listeners are
upset I got this we just it's
interesting to me these keys this guy's
life live on an autistic brothers
sharing a bunk bed that's very
interesting to me I'm sorry I'm trying
to figure out where you can jerk off
he's 20 he's got all those comments we
can't dump loads as always interesting
when you feel like someone's not being
honest with you and you can get and you
can sure anyone ever dated they always
know so I'm shy one more closer let's
hear I want to hear his parents talk to
him about sex I would like to hear that
clip I've not heard whoa okay now I want
to ask I want to find out some what was
going on boy
your head when they were trying to pick
apart everything everything about what
everything about you trying to have sex
everything with them I had it's
embarrassing you know what being 20
years old talking about sex just it's
uncomfortable just to me like my first
time I understand your parents very
Catholic the Catholic on their Catholic
enough where like you in yours what is
in your household you guys don't talk
about it yeah like what is my parents
never talked to me about such I know so
it's it's sometimes it'll be it'll come
across but you just no I just [ __ ]
they're me like oh so you having sex
like nah no obviously not but they're
not open to it do it do they believe
that you should wait first I mean their
marriage yeah they'd probably be like
just wait until you're married
he's still letting everybody answer his
questions with questions yes he is
you're just repeating what they're
saying in your answers right yeah like
so there you weren't you weren't
thinking to yourself like oh what's the
answer to this question your let me just
let me just be gay is that because you
just didn't wanna you just there were so
many lies you're like I don't want to
address this yeah yeah now are you
agreeing with me right now cuz you're
like having a lot Sam answer his own
question
is there any like is there any Nikko in
there sometimes but not always not
always I see well he's just learning out
of trouble right you've learned that
your parents are strict and you've
learned how to get out of trouble by God
you know you do yeah yeah yeah yeah yes
I'm a death Nico what's the longest
you've held on to a lie before you said
all right it's not true in general or
it's like to my parents generous in just
a lie just anyway what's the longest
you've held on to a lie before you get
finally confessed and said alright you
know what I'm just gonna just come clean
and just say I've been lying this whole
time I haven't told my parents I watched
porn you don't have they asked you if
you will not work that's a lie that's
not a lie that's talked to my mom about
she sends you the links that you held on
to that that you were telling people and
people kind of had a feeling that you
were not being honest about me and they
they pressured you impression them to
know so this is it this is yeah this one
be honest with me
are you kind of a liar I can be yeah
you're kind of a liar right yeah what do
you lie about you just get nervous and
you just end of line yeah like your
first instinct is to not tell the truth
right about sex yeah in general were you
in one of the World Trade Center towers
no I remember so what do you what do you
live in school now that by the way now
that we know that you're in schools in
two or three hold on do your school in
school a two or three I don't know he's
trying to not he does he's just giving
you the shortest answer not the curtain
real answer watch I was now that we know
that he's a liar he's a bit of a liar do
we kind of think back as to what
happened to the missing camera knew that
was coming up is the story behind the
missing camera nico stole it no I think
yeah I think he [ __ ] up in somebody
else stolen
I think he's he did something that
allowed somebody else to steal a camera
that belonged to who the Shamy yes
to this night it was my camera I brought
it in for the show like like these
cameos okay and then it one turned up
missing and he he was in charge he put
need took down the studio okay right so
and then and then over the weekend it
disappeared yeah I don't think that
Nikko would steal from us because it's
different than lying but I I could see a
scenario where he would do something
scatterbrained scatterbrained and then
and then lie about it and try to throw
Anthony what did you what did you lie
about the cameras just get it out what I
lie about they're asking you what did
you lie about with the camera I just
said that I cleaned up the studio like a
normal and maybe I did place it and I
wrong so I don't remember honestly okay
really good at impressions man he picks
up immediately Travis what do you think
about what what did you said I don't
believe you know no but also when when
you lot when when you're like a
pathological liar you believe your lives
right that's true he could totally be
believing that what he is saying right
now is true and you can pass a
lie-detector test you live in live world
yeah I don't think you stole the camera
right I do think that there's more of
light out is he the mayor you think they
are lighter that's true I just
and I love and we'll get into it as the
weeks and months progressed but I love
the dynamic like that Anthony thinks
that Nikko is on it like a lesser level
like yeah they're not on the same level
they're not both guys that lie and
they're home Larry Anthony Fox any jerks
off damn right just ask a one on
Facebook [ __ ] I jerk off you little
creep have you guys ever known someone
in your life that would just lie to you
just a friend who would just make crazy
stories about oh god yeah guys who pump
up what they do on radio and yes do what
you deal with that
oh yeah that sucks boring lies yes
what's the biggest lie that anyone's
ever like tried to stick to and you
finally caught him on
I mean I I used to deal I mean in in
school you'd always have kids doing that
like you know when we were doing Opie
and Anthony and Rob was an intern
remember he had that whole pool party
scenario and I don't need he had lied
about about I don't even it was like
this long drawn-out thing where he was
said he was trying to get people over
for a pool party and then he just ended
up lying about the whole thing but
blaming it on the weather but the
weather wasn't bad and and it was like
but it took an hour to finally get him
to be like you know I'm sorry I think
we've all known people like that the
most fascinating one I've ever seen was
this woman in Baltimore who claimed that
she won a Mega Millions or some
Powerball I know if you remember was
like four or five years ago she called
in sick to McDonald's and said I'm not
coming in and they said you're supposed
to be here at 9:00 and she said I won
the Powerball and she hung up and before
she hunt they said wait wait is it the
Powerball we all chipped in on and she
goes no and whoa this [ __ ]
yep the girl that we all just chipped in
to get money to buy tickets she won the
[ __ ] pout and now they're all getting
freaked out and they're telling all
their friends and some of their friends
call the press and she stuck to her
story for weeks
press camped out in front of her house
hey where's the Powerball and she said
the most reckless [ __ ] things you
could say there's like a half a billion
dollar ticket she walked out of her
front door and they said where's the
ticket she goes I'm hiding it they said
where are you hiding it she said it's at
the McDonald's somewhere I'm not gonna
say where oh there's a half million
dollar ticket hiding in this McDonald's
million or billion
I'm sorry half billion half billion
dollar ticket wait just somewhere that
she so people are turning the McDonald's
upside down but it's all just lies just
like go away engine cover go over there
and forget it and then they find out the
winner was actually in another state so
it was not possible this girl in
Maryland could have done it why I bought
it in another state and then brought it
back to this made it away yeah that was
the most fascinating life
I wonder she lost her job I don't know I
made friends with her on Facebook and
started supporting her like everyone was
like
people were writing awful [ __ ] to her
and I was writing hey she'll come out
when she's ready to come out right girl
and that she would like all my comments
no I was obsessed with her I was [ __ ]
obsessed with whoever great she did win
and then she married you because you
were supporting she I do remember she
had three kids from three different good
girl [ __ ] [ __ ] and she fingers herself
Nikko you should just tell the truth
going forward yeah it's it's me go is
there anything that you want to say
about the camera now before it's found
out yeah just get it off your chest just
get it off your chest to say now instead
of like good idea saying it later and
like it getting cornered for something
is there anything you want to just
reveal and just just to just to cleanse
yourself to get it out you'll be
forgiven lovable liar nothing you want
to confess about the